some good news today though for the  Windsors with the queen and her grandson  enjoying some much-needed did I say  quality time  a royal source confirms to ET that the  Queen and Harry had a one-on-one lunch  that lasted a few hours on Sunday it was  the first meeting between the two since  mex it so what happened behind closed  castle doors well the Queen reportedly  called for the face-to-face herself and  told Harry that he is quote much-loved  and will always be welcomed back if he  changes his mind about rejoining the  firm Harry arrived in the UK last week  to finish out previously scheduled  engagements and Megan will join him on  Thursday night at the endeavor fund  Awards I'm so so grateful to be back at  last year's event Megan was very  pregnant so where's Archie now we're  told the nine month old is expected to  remain in Canada with his nanny the  Queen is said to be very sad that she  will not see her great-grandson during  the visit